[Music]
there's not a face for every
culture every ethnicity every
race
so when you tell me that i'm too dark to
be dominican
show me what a dominican looks like
and then try to tell me that i'm not
dominican enough
because you're wrong
i'm dominican i'm black i'm an
afrolatina and you can't tell me any
different
[Music]
an afrolatina is simply
a person who just identifies with their
blackness
that's it i'm a black girl and my family
is from dominican republic but people
say i'm too dark to be dominican
people say
i can't be latina growing up there was
no one who looked like me i remember
just being called charcoal i remember
being called too dirty at one point i
stopped saying i was dominican my goal
is simply to be able to help the youth
feel comfortable in their skin and own
it
most people know me as monica style muse
over on youtube instagram you name it
i've been able to be extremely
successful as an afro latina in the
beauty space this is one of my favorite
eyebrow pencils because the precision
just makes your brows you know i live
for a brow lift i'm not the best makeup
artist and never did i ever say i was
but i feel like if i can at least just
inspire
other people to just live in their own
truth regardless of what other people
think
i know her because i follow her on
instagram
oh she likes me i like
her it took me maybe three years to
really find myself and to be my own muse
on my channel you can print this all
over your face to really bring the
moisture back into your face so you look
refreshed
one day i just decided you know what i'm
gonna be myself
at first when i started speaking spanish
on my channel they were like can you
stop this can you just make a separate
channel and i said you know what no this
is who i am and it was the best decision
i've ever made for myself being a latina
means knowing that you have a culture
and a background and a story that can't
also be taken from you my audience is
this sassy
person who is just so ready to take on
whatever the world throws at them
they're going to figure it out one way
or another and that's what i've done
even like thinking back to little monika
baby monica was so timid she was so
scared of the world i'm an adult now you
can't really phase me cause
which means if my shine bothers you
that's not my problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
go through some beads
hip-hop allows you to be the voice for
the voiceless
when i met isaiah i didn't know what to
expect
once i had an opportunity to communicate
with him i was like
nah he can he can talk he can talk he
has no problem talking and let's figure
out how we want to end the song out how
we want to close it when i think of
isaiah as an artist i more so feel that
he's a poet he's writing poetry he's
talking about his experiences i don't
care what people think of me pride and
honor that they carry me drunk going but
i love myself like a lion to my family
first record that isaiah and i did was
oxygen to fly he wrote it always the
voice had to dream around the other day
it's a challenge to be someone else's
voice
but isaiah has so many things that he
wants to say we find a way to make it
work
yeah yeah okay well next week uh we can
work on the second verse before i worked
with isaiah i had a heavy presence in
the uh
local scene as far as rap music um as
well as uh some community work all right
we're gonna take it from the top okay we
were able to come together and kind of
amplify our message and that's just that
you shouldn't stand to the side and do
nothing if you're fully capable of doing
something i brought out a special guest
tonight man his name is isaiah the
rapper y'all doing me a favor make some
noise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was always big
my story was that i was fat and i was
sort of doomed to be fat and unhappy and
and not live the life that i wanted to
live so being able to break down that
story it's been a lifelong process for
me and that's what i really am aiming to
share with other people is that that
story doesn't have to be true
[Music]
i'm dana falcetti and i am a yoga
teacher
yoga is for everyone
[Music]
why do people need to be skinny to do
yoga this is it's just it doesn't even
make sense to me the only thing that you
need to practice yoga is the willingness
to try
welcome
so even bigger breath on this inhale so
belly rises up towards the sky
rock the hips from side to side just
anything that feels good
i travel all over the world teaching
body positive workshops so i don't
necessarily teach in a way that is about
modifying or making the practice easier
for anybody based on age or size or
anything like that it's more about
teaching in a way that makes everyone
feel really included and really
comfortable and lift the left arm up i
don't care what it looks like
i don't care what any of you look like
just do it and just feel amazing
from like age 10 or so on i was always
big
three years ago i started going to the
gym and just being really active in the
pursuit to get smaller and i lost almost
100 pounds
i got to my new body and everything was
exactly the same i wasn't happier and i
didn't feel any better and so i was at
this point where i felt really just kind
of lost and confused about
what i needed and so i went to yoga
before
i practiced i didn't realize how
capable my body was because i just felt
like it was fat and like i was lazy and
i believed everything about my body that
sort of society sees when they see a fat
person
i love my body which is crazy because i
really spent my whole life hating it i
mean looking in the mirror and just
feeling so disgusting and i'm proud of
it now and i'm proud to take care of it
[Music]
when i first started climbing i was so
bad
i was so terrible so slow i'd tear my
skin up all the time
i was like how the heck are we going to
go and do mount kilimanjaro
three words i don't know
those three words three of the most
important words in my life all
discoveries happen from i don't know
my name is kyle maynard
and i have an extremely hard time saying
what it is exactly that i do
i've been an athlete my entire life
football to wrestling to weightlifting
and brazilian jiu jitsu and now most
recently taking on climbing some of the
highest mountains in the world
i was born with congenital amputation so
it basically means my arms and at the
elbows my legs and at the knees
you know i think some people they look
at me and maybe even feel sorry for me
but really truthfully my life doesn't
look a whole lot different than yours
you know i type on my computer the same
way you know i use my phone just like
anybody else i'm on bumble like anybody
any other single person my age
my first experience with climbing really
anything of significance was in a
crossfit competition in 2010
the first workout was you had to do a
thousand meter row in this rowing
machine and a sprint upstone mountain
everybody else did it and maybe 25
minutes
it took me an hour and 46 minutes i tore
all the skin up on my arms but i got to
the top and i was like wow this is
breathtakingly beautiful
and i told my friend that night i said i
want to climb mount kilimanjaro
i don't know if i can i don't know if i
can't but i do know that i want to try
to figure it out
i want to go and find a way and get up
there
there were a ton of challenges with
getting into climbing and the biggest
one was the gear
i literally started with bath towels
duct taped on my arms and my feet
i couldn't go to the store and buy a
typical pair of shoes we had to come up
with a unique solution
[Music]
now to climb i use a carbon fiber
special custom shoe
i use those to bear crawl up kilimanjaro
then me and my team we took on climbing
mount akicago at the highest peak in
south america
i felt my body was like in full shutdown
mode
and it was brutal at moments but it was
breathtakingly beautiful
at the top of that mountain you know you
can almost kind of make out and see like
the curvature of the earth
i mean it was just a moment i'll never
forget
[Music]
the reasons i climb aren't that
different from other people
95 of it does suck i'm staring at the
dirt i'm not even able to go and talk to
my friends and see the beautiful views
unless i stop and sit down and look but
that five percent that doesn't suck
it's amazing
get into a place that there's no way my
wheelchair could have brought me there
that's what i love
i'm not trying to live to be a thousand
like i wanna i wanna go out there and
have my life mean something
when i've gotten down and i've looked at
the mountain and i see what we've
achieved it's like wow maybe that was a
really bad idea that we were there but
it was beautiful
you